[Musique]
voilà new york on est parti pour aller
découvrir les nouveaux xl nouveau
smartphone de longueuil pixels 4
c'est le calcul serait a priori il ya
pas mal de choses intéressantes à me
lâcher avec tous mes homologues
étrangers il ya du monde c'est cool il
ya beaucoup de bruit si beaucoup de
voyageurs dont beaucoup de roms à nadal
en train de cuire des musiques de tous
les côtés donc c'est cool mais c'est
relatif
ça
n est ce pas
[Musique]
mais cela
la connaît
comment ce qu'est
enfin il raconte ce qui va commencer
d'ici peu de temps on arrive donc en
avant première on découvre on voit ce
que ça donne et on va passer sa batterie
si maintenant on va faire un petit déj
parce qu'ils membres il ya un moment
avoir une journée très grosse il faut se
remplir il faut se nourrir sinon on va
mourir dans pêche est mon collègue
allemand et non
[Rires]
[Musique]
why à la concurrence a commencé hier pas
de regarder l'heure
ça s'est remplie
les côté noir de monde je pense que ça
va être une façon plutôt intéressante on
va rejoindre il va rappeler différent
polisse son principe je trouve ça bien
téléobjectif
c'est le gros focus qui va effectivement
sur la photo surtout que cette 4c
vraiment l'être ce qu'il a vendu parce
que toutes ces trois avaient été tout
simplement excellent là dessus on a un
objectif principal un grand temps et on
a un téléobjectif
ici pas d'ultra grand-angle ya des
choses qu'on ne pourra pas faire avec ce
pixel 4 qu'on peut faire avec un iphone
notamment après effectivement le rendu à
l'air vraiment content gros focus sur la
partie logicielle qui est la grosse
force de frappe en tout cas de google
docs
on va regarder ce que ça dit on va le
prendre en main on va le tester alors là
je vous parle effectivement je redis que
la prise en main et on parlera d'une
thèse dans quelques jours le couple se
familiariser avec moi
[Musique]
une autre
alors qu'est ce donc you think
ça rime
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
devinez ce qu'on fait deviner où on est
aujourd'hui on est effectivement à new
york c'est le soleil en pleine tronche
mais on est dans un spot qui est juste
incroyable
regardez derrière vous avez lower
manhattan qui est là vous avez si vous
le regardez là le one world trade center
vous avez la statue de la liberté si
vous regardez elle est quelque part par
à ça un petit peu loin
on est là effectivement pour parler des
google pixels 4 est vachement de trucs
cool aujourd'hui c'est énorme et c'est
vachement cool pas vous en parler ici on
est sur le toit du monde on est chez
google
et là on est franchement bien
franchement respirer cet air on prend de
la hauteur aux problèmes titude avec
l'automne arrive en arrière c'est juste
[Musique]
auckland et la livraison des tic 7 400 m
1 pouces et leucate et pizzas je pense
qu'on n'est pas des meilleurs c'est toi
de malgus ça c'est extrêmement drôle
la livraison de pizzas avec coop la
photo personnalisés on n'y est pas mal
c'est énorme
alors qu'est ce qu'on a ici saida
borders pays google c'est je crois le
plus beau packaging que je vais avoir
recours aux smartphones toute la petite
boîte comme ça avec mon pixel 4 je fais
tout tomber ça c'est le meilleur run
boxing que je crois que j'aurais jamais
fait dans une boîte à pizza attendait
j'attrape et je lève oi oi oi oi
le smartphone est juste là ça c'est
hypra cool aussi toutes les instructions
pour pouvoir l'utiliser
franchement ça je crois que c'est la
meilleure boîte que j'ai jamais vu de
toute ma vie si je vous reçois et là une
bonne vieille pizza regardez-moi ça là
ça c'est juste énorme
[Musique]
auj
google télescope je pense qu'avec ça sur
le roof top on peut voir bien ça hyper
impressionnant
personnellement déjà ce que j'aime bien
lorsque je le vois comme ça c'est la
prise en main on a un format qui est pas
trop si c'est un gamin
j'aime bien ça les formats 5,8 pouces
moi perso je suis assez fan j'aime
beaucoup alors effectivement il ya
d'autres smartphones que j'aime bien
comment on va le plus est des pros qui
assez gros mais regardez si j'avais
mieux côte à côte
on est quand même dans deux mondes
différents on va pas chercher la même
chose mais ce petit format je l'avais
déjà une 1ère avec le pixel 3 j'aimais
beaucoup ce tout petit format
après ce qui est un peu différent sur ce
smartphone c'est qu'effectivement on va
voir vous voyez les la grande bordure en
haut ça on va pas y couper grande bord
durant aux grandes bordure en bas bon
voilà ça c'est le truc qu'on va aimer ou
qu'on va pas aimer le dos en verre
d'arrière voyez ça c'est un truc qu'on
aime ou n'aime pas fait beaucoup
d'heureux fait ça va être compliqué ça a
photographié le module photo avec double
module photo fin double autres capteurs
et objectifs importants on n'a pas eu
travaux en grand-angle il était
l'objectif
à côté de ça vous avez de la recharge en
usb c'est haut parleur mono ici deuxième
au phare leur en face à toi c'est pas
mal le bouton blanc ça je trouve ça
assez joli c'est plutôt plutôt pas mal
bouton pour le volume de l'autre côté on
a le tiroir de corse île qu'est situé à
mons en principe je trouve plutôt cool
faut me laisser un peu de temps parce
qu'il faut vraiment que je maîtrise que
j'apprenne en tout cas le prendre en
main y avoir toutes ces nouvelles
fonctionnalités et ça je vous en parle
dans quelque chose
m
[Musique]
ça c'est énorme tellement drôle mais
google space euros 14 étages et ben plus
quoi cet état je crois eh bien vous avez
des trottinettes en libre-service à
droite à gauche
pouvez vous déplacer légaré
elle
ils sont
pour une petite balade chez google mais
thomas espère rien visite visite et met
plus à parler du space à new york
[Musique]
tout ce qu'il faut pour avoir la laine
pour sentir bon ou pas n'a donc
événement vraiment cool il plein plein
de choses aujourd'hui qu'ils ont été
présentés où j'ai fait le plein plein de
trucs de présenter et surtout un crew un
tout nouveau smartphone made by google
ça c'est vraiment vraiment cool le pixel
4 alors moi j'ai vraiment hâte de
pouvoir le tester le pouvoir que sa vie
ce soir on a une petite échappée
nocturne pour aller se tester je vous
mets ce à la suite de la vidéo mais j'ai
pas le droit de vous montrer tout de
suite le rendu de ce que je vais faire
en photo nue je peux vous montrer
uniquement les photos prises avec la
caméra principale
on va attendre quelques jours il ya un
embargo déjà le temps de bien le
programme a pour moi que ensuite
attendre la levée de l'embargo ça
éviterait un petit peu les problèmes
alors justement c'est vachement tard ça
parce que j'ai
pixels 4 j'en ai 2 g/l 4 15 puis surtout
une fois de plus cette pixels 4 kgs
j'allais là pour mieux protéger c'est
très très important de protéger votre
smartphone et vous invite également à
mieux protéger avec ce que vous propose
rhinochill cette petite coque de
protection qui va venir qui pourra venir
vous sauver la vie
et ça croyez moi c'est vraiment très
très très important vous prenez votre
smartphone vous le mettez dedans bien au
chaud vous avez un smartphone qui est
complètement protégé ça c'est vraiment
il prêt il paraît important de protéger
parfois dit je vous le dis une fois de
plus parce que si vous l'échappée vous
le faites tomber vous avez un truc qui
se cassent et là pendant qu'on parle
c'est la loose d'ailleurs cette corne de
rhino chez vous intéresse vous avez une
remise de 10% avec le code monsieur
breveté tous marqué en bas dans la
description donc un smartphone qui est
vraiment qu'on va faire un tour du côté
de la boîte très rapidement pour que je
vous montre un peu ce qu'on a à
l'intérieur ça normalement l'écriture
monsieur re vous n'avez pas assez
spécialement pour monsieur grossesse que
voit la petite histoire
qu'est-ce qu'on retrouve ensuite ici à
l'intérieur ça ça va être quoi ça on a
découvert son tiroir de cartes sim
on a les cartes de garantie on aide les
docks on a de la câblerie intérieur
câble usb c'est usb c'est pour me dire
leur charge et ça c'est un adaptateur
usb wusb sait et on a un bloc de charge
rapide je crois que c'est le bloc 18
watts nord sas et voilà c'est quand vous
prenez votre chargeur aux us et bien
vous avez un bloc américain heureusement
j'ai un adaptateur en france ça va
pouvoir sauver la vie pour moi tout le
plus important c'est les double capteur
photo que vous avez ici c'est vraiment
le truc a fait le succès du pixel 3
pixels 3xl et continue effectivement
google et aides reçues cette fois ci
nous met deux capteurs photo un capteur
normal quand on écrit tim ans le
téléobjectif l'idée effectivement
c'était l'objectif si vous avez un mode
photo de nuit qui va encore plus loin
pour avoir différentes expositions où
une exposition longue qui va pouvoir
aller jusqu'à 4 minutes d'exposition
pour vouloir faire de
l'astrophotographie photographier le
ciel photographier les autres ça ça a
l'air vraiment très très bon surtout
extrêmement maîtrisé c'est la force de
frappe en fin de compte si vous voulez
de de google c'est l'algorithme et ça
marche parfaitement bien avoir
effectivement ce que ça donnait sur ce
smartphone comme jodie une fois de plus
on en reparle d'ici quelques jours mais
mon avis ça va être vraiment rien
topissime il ya c'est le truc qui est
vachement intéressant on en parle aussi
d'ici quelques jours c'est motion ça
vous passez votre nom de vent pourraient
venir refuser un appel vous pouvez
switcher d'un morceau à l'autre tout ça
on le teste or en reparlera aussi d'ici
quelques jours le temps que je vois
vraiment comment ça marche je donnerai
mon retour complet là dessus vous avez
aussi notre fonctionnalité majeure c'est
la prise de notes vocales vous prenez
votre smartphone vous enregistrez ils
vont reconnaître le texte alors
effectivement pour l'instant ça ne
marcherait pas en anglais on louera
prochainement en france mais imaginez ça
vous reconnaît votre texte ensuite vous
traduisez ça vous fait un truc est
vraiment génial vous pouvez donc dicter
un texte
ensuite vous traduisez vous l'envoyez ça
c'est vraiment cool ap a maintenant
commencé à intégrer si ça marche
vraiment bien si a pas de faute
sans le vert aussi très très
prochainement en termes de tarifs c'est
là où ça devient très intéressant ça
smartphone qui sera disponible à partir
du 24 octobre disponible chez sur le
site de google bien évidemment fnac
darty boulanger je vous met les liens en
description vous inquiétez pas et
question tarifs
il sera disponible le pixel 4 à 769
euros et modèle xl à 899 euros
alors il y eut également tout l'ensemble
tout l'écosystème google com qui
remaniée qui s'appelle aujourd'hui nef
naissent minique ça on va par là aussi
ultérieurement on va parler un petit peu
tout ce qu'on peut faire avec google a
un atout clé il fonctionner tout ce que
google peut faire pour vous on en
reparlera plus tard donc rester
connectés et venez vous si ce n'est pas
déjà le cas on va en tout cas que google
continue sa progression dans les foyers
continuent à aller plus loin
intéressant maintenant à voir si ce
design va plaire s'il fait qu'il n'y ait
pas un ultra grand-angle par rapport à
fond pour trouver la concurrence est ce
que ça va plaire oui ou non on a un
écran oled de 5,7 pouces de diagonale
fhd plus à 4 144 pixels par pouces
format 19/9 mais surtout tout le plus
intéressant c'est qu'on a un écran 90
hertz c'est-à-dire un écran extrêmement
fluide le pixel cats est un smartphone
que je trouve assez léger pour ma part
que je trouve vraiment bien en termes de
prise en main qui fait 162 grammes c'est
pas mal de pouvoir un petit peu revenir
avec des smartphones très léger comme ça
très fin ces petits formats je trouve
moi en tout cas
aussi toujours très très séduisant côté
batterie c'est pas énorme on a une
batterie de 2800 milieu en perdant c'est
un petit peu le le point faible que moi
j'allais reprocher une 1ère au pixel 3
c'est l autonomie du modèle on va voir
si celui-là avec le pixel 4,7 à mieux
toujours un sera vous avez un chargeur
rapide de 18 watts à l'intérieur il
tourne avec instinct dragon 855 il assis
giga de ram et 64 giga de stockage
on a donc deux caméras l'arrière une
caméra principale de 12 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f
1.7 avec un champ de vision de 77 degrés
et une deuxième caméra synthé l'objectif
de 16 mégapixels avec une ouverture de f
points 4 avec un champ de vision de 52
degrés dans les deux cas n'a de la
stabilisation optique et électronique
tandis qu'à l'avant on a une petite
caméra ici de 8 mégapixels qui ouvre à f
2.0 et qui est un champ de vision de 90
degrés dernière partie de la journée ont
fait un petit tour à brooklyn pour aller
se faire des shoots de photos nuit
lorsque vous ne montre pas pour
l'instant on en reparlera plus tard
lorsque la lever l'embargo sera fait que
j'aurais le droit de diffuser ces images
pour que la musique la station
d'épuration de new york
un petit peu comment ça marche bon là on
voit pas de retour de la station
d'épuration va pas tout dit et les
courriers mais on va pouvoir faire des
photos de nuit parce qu'en fait ici
c'est vrai on croit voir une pièce nous
fait très sombre et on va pas en
pollution etc stable pour venir tester
en tout cas là la nouvelle photo de nuit
de ce pic 7,4 avec mon équipe et
protection de l'environnement
est-ce que je suis pas boxeur plutôt pas
mal
non
c'est sur cette visite que je vais vous
laisser on va maintenant les mots jean
marie payet tranquillement je donne
rendez vous demain pour de nouvelles
aventures je ne sais pas ce qu'on va pas
rire plein de choses à faire et puis
départ pour lisbonne c'est jeudi on va
les barbots pro voilà ça continue il ya
plein de choses à faire sur ce ne vous
embrasse et vous dire de marque tôt